[Music]
Northern California police officer says
a routine patrol led to a life-changing
event when a homeless woman asked him to
adopt her baby girl John Blackstone
introduces us to a family going above
and beyond the call of duty you like the
bread with three daughters under 8 years
old Jessi and Ashleigh Witten already
had a full house you had a family yes a
complete family they didn't need to add
anybody to it we're planning on adding
anybody to why I think I think it's when
you see a need you just need to show up
and that's what parenthood in our
experience says anyway as a 10-year
veteran of the Santa Rosa Police
Department Jessi befriended a pregnant
homeless woman with a drug addiction
whom he frequently ran into while on
patrol I was trying to get her there
were times I got her shelter at
different different locations sometimes
she would take me up on and sometimes
she wouldn't then his wife met her on a
ride-along last August
her and I got to talking and she was
very obviously pregnant and so I said oh
you're pregnant and she grabbed my hand
and she put it on her stomach and I had
no idea that a year later out the baby I
was feeling in her womb was would be our
daughter in February they got an
unexpected life-changing call the birth
mother had specifically asked for the
Witten's to adopt her child
they agreed despite concerns about the
baby's health you have to think that a
mother who's drug-addicted having a baby
the baby's gonna have some big problems
right we didn't know what to expect we
we knew that we were gonna take her no
matter what but yeah but we were like is
this gonna be something that she's gonna
be hooked up to two tubes the rest of
her life she did go through some
withdrawals she had some shaking and
they were worried about some seizures
now they say she's hitting all the
normal baby milestones and is expected
to lead a healthy life she's got the
sweetest disposition she's so nice she's
over been killed
she's really engaged though she's very
observant she observes everything smiles
all the time
and with permission from her new sisters
yes
Harlow was officially adopted by the
family last week there's enough love
there's enough love for her there's
enough love to go important more than
enough the Witten's are still in contact
with Harlow's biological mother and are
sharing baby photos with her as an
officer with a duty to protect and to
serve Witten says he's serving a higher
purpose with a new perspective on the
job you got a lot of years of police
work ahead of you I do are you gonna be
careful about how you deal with people I
think so I don't think it I don't think
it's deterred me though you know I I
think I'm open to what relationships and
connections that I make I think we could
just trust that whatever this line of
work wherever it takes our family that's
where we want to go we just want to
serve our community obviously I wasn't
expecting this or asking for this but
I'm really glad that happened for CBS
this morning John Blackstone Center Rosa
California is a great family